welcome to this video playing war habit
why on earth of a plane before I was
just thinking okay let's play stuff you
know okay yeah maybe maybe maybe let's
go for tech more technical type of
position go for the exchange rule Lopez
how is this plate rock d3 as long as I
know yeah I didn't want to play such a
natural stuff let him take it's still an
end game that I can play I mean take on
a three of course whoa I habit yeah
there's really lots of players from them
from the Nordic countries even before
magnus carlsen was arriving on the scene
they really have always have been many
many players from from sweden norway
finland on the soc okay should I prepare
Knight to c4 maybe but I have another
idea I could put the night on d3 this is
an improvement ticking Oh interesting
yeah I don't want to place you form
because of 96 this feels feels like a
wrong decision but I don't want to allow
him to play play see form see play see
for himself
sc3 a good move I don't know it feels a
bit weakening but 94 is really something
that would help him Knight see for know
maybe night between the night c4 maybe
it feels really a bit weird to plant
plenty exchange Rui as white I've
defended against it's quite often as
black but this is some not so typical
position for the exchange rate at least
them I never played a line that features
the structure okay he's retreating maybe
I should introduce the idea of Bishop
f-22 g3 hmm do I want to trade ropes not
sure I'd like to get the King to eat
tool this is clear
hmm really another pawn on dark squares
yeah that is surprising yeah he might go
g-form if I played G for myself it's
it's very very closed not sure that I
like that ok I it's difficult to play
this position without getting rooks off
so let's do that
b5 I think is just weakening c5 yes
marussia my my rationale behind the
lower that was that at the end i will
have f4 and i've got this this is this
pass out to really should that tree
looks i'm not sure one pair certainly
but not to maybe look at Brooke h1 rook
age 5 or look aged six this arm moves
that can be can be annoying for black
yes I should I should keep one walk via
via this is helpful I am I simply am in
a position where my rook is quicker with
the tacking stuff like the bishops and
end upon he really cannot attack much
here mostly because my king is only two
and it protects the the entry squares
and so on okay this was clear eyes got
be form maybe before yeah but even after
see 494 check the nights are are quite
good then it's so closed I don't before
I also have maybe Roxy one not sure or
just take it maybe just take it yeah I
can also just take it
yeah yeah now we would get to this
position Roxy one takes rook takes
Knight d4 check and why should I can
take I mean if I take and turn in at the
night takes its he's threatening night
see to taking at Bishop g5 nya takes
Knight eggs yeah that's that's total
threat ok night chapel I can I can also
just move the king it's no no problem to
f2 and ISS check on edge form
the RT and the real question is am I am
I blundering material or not if I'm not
then a channel I'm winning by porn
structure wife of the why he's got a
tech now look d7 G seven
hmm this is dangerous oh my ah no no
he's gotten the tech now 20 seconds no
ah this is really frustrating at the
moment and black black was completely
outplayed completely I just changed her
diminish the counter play and now it's
it's in full swing check check time
mornings from this still good for me
Bishop g5 is not even possible I came
night c4 but the time is the problem
check check check check check mate yeah
come on I need to stop I need to stop
this session for bloody [ __ ] they did I
mean what what kind of position do I
want I mean black is full of weaknesses
and I mean even see for just wins yeah I
mean this is probably also good but he's
got counter play and it's not necessary
the thing is that all falls all black
pants are weak and they will fall just
one after the other if I'm playing this
correctly ok let's look at this this is
the easiest way to go check and cake and
we can look at this I'd this type of
position where did these two pawns are
hanging and he starts to lose stuff now
it's absolutely impossible to to keep
keep the material chat right something
like that awesome yeah he keeps the porn
but what kind of position is this just
I'm just advancing with two passes you
can try try that check have the smooth
yeah it's flat-out winning compass on
plus two so C 4 wins and this is what I
played probably wins as well but it
check it is some counter play maybe I
should just take it this is also just
good why didn't that take it I mean also
very easy no of course not come on this
is what I'm trying to do then check take
here yeah some move this and c5 is gone
this is the easiest in fact ok I'm going
here check and chaplain this is again
just winning for check can only need to
avoid to to run into one of those one
movers check even here so these are two
pawns yeah but I don't have any time I
actually am check simply overlooked that
that I can I can just take here come on
ok let's stop this video I need to break
help